last night Donald Trump lost it on
Twitter he lashed out in a bizarre and
outrageous stream of tweets boiling with
rage and resentment he was slamming
House Speaker Paul Ryan for basically
cutting him loose and saying I want to
show up anywhere with Trump this is a
meltdown unprecedented by a presidential
nominee let's start with the first tweet
here about Paul Ryan it is so of this
not directly about Paul Ryan but we'll
get to that Trump saying it is so nice
that the shackles have been taken off me
and i can now fight for America the way
I want to well what is the way that
Trump wants to fight for America
apparently with no help from the
Republican Party and certainly no help
from Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
tweeting about Paul Ryan uh that our
very weak and ineffective leader Paul
Ryan had a bad conference call where his
members went wild at his disloyalty
continuing to tweet about Paul Ryan
increasingly unhinged an implosive
Donald Trump saying despite winning the
second debate in a landslide every poll
untrue by the way it is hard to do well
when Paul Ryan and others give zero
support and then why not might as well
go after John McCain as well who
recently rescinded his endorsement of
Donald Trump saying uh the very foul
mouth Senator John McCain begged for my
support during his primary I gave he won
then dropped me over locker room remarks
uh III mean that this this is just
absolutely insane what is going on here
John McCain universally liked Republican
heck I said when he was running against
Obama if it had to be a Republican John
McCain is definitely one of the better
ones and then Trump called out
Republicans who are supporting him as
being worse than crooked Hillary pretty
bad when you call members of your own
party worse than the opposition here's
another tweet from Donald Trump disloyal
Republicans are far more difficult than
crooked Hillary they come at you from
all sides they don't know how to win I
will teach them and then going even
further with one more tweet saying with
the exception of cheating Bernie out of
the nomination the
dems have always proven to be far more
loyal to each other then to the
Republicans Trump has gone rogue this is
an arky and now Republican leaders are
sort of in a tough position what do you
do if you're the Republican Party
they've already stopped funding the
victory direct mail campaign to help
Donald Trump ben Carson is questioning
his support for Donald Trump Armstrong
Williams who's a spokesperson for Carson
said dr. Carson has been unwavering in
his support but the last 24 hours have
made that support very difficult to
maintain I get emails from people guys
saying hey everything Trump is doing is
normal is just running a campaign he's
sticking to the issues he's going after
people they're going after him that's it
no we know Trump holds grudges Trump is
resentful he's aggressive he tries to
destroy his enemies and enemies I
applaud unshackling Trump because it is
leading to a meltdown of historic
proportions and does he not realize too
that you need these people in the house
in the Senate right you want to get your
legislation passed I me a part of the
reason why he chose Mike Pence's is
running mate was so that he could kind
of work with the Republicans in Congress
and get the things he wanted to done
yeah i mean if if you god forbid he were
to become president how is he going to
do any of his crazy stuff if he doesn't
even have the support of his own party
and obviously democrats aren't going to
be supporting the guy meltdown an
implosion of historic proportions on
Twitter the fact that we keep reporting
on Trump's Twitter meltdowns is not
exactly a sign that inspires confidence
in the future leader of the free world
that when he gets his phone and is left
alone to tweet on on Twitter everything
falls apart not good i'm on twitter yet
rachel go ahead right but i feel like
his supporters continue to kind of
redirect this into something that's
actually positive and saying that he's a
fearless in the way that he will attack
people who attacked him and in return on
the largest get i know it sounds
ridiculous but extrapolating not to mean
that if someone is attacking our country
not that the way that he's doing this is
productive at all but that he is going
to stand up for himself and his
supporters and he's going to kind of be
they're in that sense I think that you
have done an interpretation with Trump
colored glasses that does represent what
a lot of trumpeters believe and
hopefully that number is small enough
that this guy gets crushed on november
eighth we'll see warby parker is
offering a free five day home try-on to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses i personally wear warby
parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try-on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com / TDPS I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / tdps it costs nothing